pour le trophée de la race rare
[Musique]
agathe au bout
agathe vous allez rentrer sur scène via
le mode histoire mais jamais arrêté
l'été
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lisez
[Musique]
ressent la pluie
ce plat
votre
est-ce véronique et stocker bâle à côté
d'un gâteau presse commentant des
véroniques vers les deux chansons et là
oh mon dieu
la peau et je suis désolé comment
va-t-on sortir de l'anonymat
[Applaudissements]
il a fait sa place dans le sport elle ou
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas une quête qui va m'empêcher d'en
il réagit comme ça
c'est pas comme ça
[Applaudissements]
et camille combal
martina et isoler ainsi qu'à nuit
[Applaudissements]
aussi bon avec mon ami non non non je
sais pas
je sais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on est amis voici ce qu'il était
en ondes et non d'essayer de rédaction
chaise moi pour vous c'est la chaîne qui
semblait mal hs gagnant cyril hanouna
aussi les arrêts et l'émotion je suis
pas bien écouté chez vous avez brain
shake up un petit peu france entend tout
à l'heure mais tout va bien